i mean chess is so harsh just one slip  one wrong move in a promising position  and suddenly your opponent has  everything  and magnus still focused still  calculating but by this point he knows  that he's about to win uh things masters  and okay magnus just waiting for the  hammer to fall  the pony actually about to resign about  to give up  okay  moments away from the trophy  what a hard fought and fantastic final  by ana pognati we know he's been  under a lot of pressure a lot of things  has been on his mind it must have been  hard to focus he has played some  fantastic games  but there it is  it ends here magnus carlsen winning two  games today he is the winner of the air  things master after an incredible final  with a great jana pognachi by magnus  carlsen showing  his genius in this final we've had  incredible fighting chess